the only way to deal with fear that I
found in my life is a couple ways one of
those ways is to turn it on itself and
ask yourself what am I afraid of I'm
free of that I got to be more afraid of
what I'm gonna miss out on missing out
on my mission missing out who I'm
supposed to be missing in other words if
you're not get get rid of fear than use
fear use fear or it uses you it's that
simple so you gotta say okay what's the
price if I just stay doing this what's
the price what I need to really to get
scared if I learn all this I don't fall
through that's something to be scared
about
and then that fear will get you over
your feet it'll push you through turn
fear on itself second way you can do it
is use what you've probably heard me say
because I've used this number 17 is my
little rocking chair test right
I'm gonna sit myself in my rocking chair
I'm 85 years old I'm looking back on my
life and I say I didn't do this or I did
I think everybody has fear all wrong
people have so many theories about fear
they talk about while I'm afraid of
success no I'm afraid of failure I'm
afraid of intimacy I'm afraid of heights
I'm afraid of this I'm afraid of that
I'm afraid of the other thing there's
actually only two fears only two
and if you're in sales which you are or
even if you're not
life is about persuading people life is
about influencing people and fear is the
invisible force that will make you
ineffective at that it will stop you now
I love JK Rollins as an example I mean
we all know the Harry Potter series but
what a lot of people don't know about
her she talks a lot about fear she
struggled with major depression do you
know she was unemployed and she wrote
the original idea for Harry Potter on a
napkin while she was on state benefits
she was then rejected by 12 publishing
houses and this by the way was after she
was divorced bankrupt and a single mom
of a kid pushed herself pushed herself
pushed herself she talks a lot about
fear and about failure well you know we
know the moral of the story she just
kept going of course she was afraid but
she had the good kind of fear not the
bad kind of fear
a life dominated by doubt and fear how
do you step into bravery
step
that's how you step in a bravery step
take the step step aggressively towards
your fear and that that step towards
your fear is the step into bravery
because we're scared of what we don't
know and there is only one way to learn
and to know and that is to confront that
fear you have to step you have to go and
this simple action
this simple attitude it answers so many
questions my theory here would be if
you're afraid of fighting and
altercations go change it so if you're
afraid of heights work on some rock
climbing if you're afraid of the water
the time to swim it's time to surf is
trying to get out there if you're afraid
of public speaking go speak in public if
you're afraid to start a business start
a business make it small and on all
these what you have to do is you have to
mitigate the risk and you have to ease
yourself into it but you got to go for
it and eventually you will overcome that
fear
but the hard part is you gotta take that
first step you've got to take that first
step to begin to inoculate yourself
against the fear against the fear of the
thing that's in your mind because that
fear generally is in your mind when you
get up on stage do a public speaking
people are not gonna throw tomatoes at
you and say oh my
you're an idiot get off the stage no
they're gonna sit there you know so
there's nothing to fear it's in it's in
your head
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed this is a new test
series for us and I would love to know
what you thought about it your your
opinions your feedback did you like you
did you hate it you want to see more how
can we make it better let me know down
in the comments below I also want to
make sure you are moving from just
consuming a video to actually taking
action so I have three things for you to
think about three questions write them
down for yourself talk about them with a
friend or leave your answers in the
comments below here we go question
number one what fear do you need to step
into question but two how can this fear
serve you and question number three what
do you need to do to push yourself
through the fear thank you guys so much
for watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much loved see
you soon altruistic world domination
honey Empire right I'm grateful I
understand why I'm here I think because
I am so open I wanted to think and see
it's a bloody brief life all of you have
the potential for enormous success if
you want to know what gary vee DJ khalid
oprah and others know about empire
building that most people miss check out
the link in the description for a free
bonus video